here's a question do you care who builds
your roads or your bridges
does it matter to you who built your
rubbish dumps
or for that matter your trains or your
railways
wherever you live in the world all these
things are crucial to our lives
but as long as they work safely they
don't cost too much
and there's no corruption involved it
probably doesn't feel like it really
matters who builds them
but what about our communication
networks
well they could be a different matter
next generation super fast 5g networks
are being rolled out
all over the world you might not have
noticed
in monaco they're hiding some of the
gear away
in creative ways but 5g
is being touted as a breakthrough today
we're bringing 5g to iphone both
apple and google have jumped on it with
their latest new
phones but experts say 5g goes far
deeper
opening up whole new applications in
areas from advanced
medicine to manufacturing 5g has the
potential to really
trigger a new wave of industrialization
because
it will be the foundation for data
transmission
in industry 4.0 so industrial production
but also for applications like
autonomous driving
it all means that 5g will be much more
embedded in our societies than
anything that went before which means
that we
really need to trust it and that's the
dilemma facing countries
everywhere right now can they trust the
current leader in 5g technology huawei
a company from china america says the
answer is clearly no
donald trump has pulled the plug on
huawei having any involvement in us 5g
networks
and his secretary of state has been
telling american allies in europe
that they must do the same as a matter
of chinese law
the chinese government can rightfully
demand access to data flowing through
huawei and zte systems
why would anyone grant such power to
regime that has already grossly violated
cyberspace and that tough line is not
expected to change under incoming
president joe biden
some might see an irony in america's
warnings
its own track record here is hardly
spotless
the snowden leaks in 2013 showed that
its nsa had used so-called back door
vulnerabilities in u.s made network
equipment
to tap into vast amounts of internet
traffic
could chinese intelligence do the same
with huawei gear
there's a big concern that
the company itself might build
in vulnerabilities into the code that
cannot be discovered very easily
and these vulnerabilities seem
accidental or might seem accidental
but in fact they might be there on
purpose or even if they are accidental
and they
find them afterwards the company could
exploit them
um the company not because of its own
interest
but because it might be forced by the
chinese government to do so
underpinning that concern is the fact
that as a chinese company
huawei is ultimately subject to the
authority of china's ruling communist
party
or ccp insists
that there are no back doors in its
equipment and that it has
no notable ties with the chinese
government
we spoke to its chief representative
here in berlin
huawei has no special relations with any
governments
compared to any other private companies
or across the world
with their governments and
that is the fact but huawei's founder
ren jung fei
has personally been a member of the
communist party since the 1970s
and experts say the party's power over
all chinese firms
is enshrined in law the national
intelligence law itself in article 7
says that all chinese people and
organizations including companies
must support assist and cooperate with
national intelligence gathering
now the same law also says that
people and organizations in china must
maintain
secrecy over this requirement
and over these activities so therefore
if you like
not only are people and companies in
china obligated to
assist in national intelligence
gathering but they're also obligated
to deny in public that they are doing so
this degree of state power over chinese
companies
is what creates the greatest anxiety in
european capitals
especially in the light of china's
increasingly
authoritarian behavior
china has shocked the world with its
crackdown on freedoms in hong kong
and it's rolling out a massive
surveillance apparatus
to monitor its entire population both
online
and offline the argument goes that if
that's how
china treats its own people how much can
it care about people
in other parts of the world about their
rights to privacy for example or free
speech
or about the national security of the
countries that they live in
the new us as these questions grow more
insistent
some european countries have changed
their minds about huawei
this summer britain said it was freezing
the company out
france and sweden have made similar
moves
here in germany the government has been
trying to make up its mind
it's not like there's no alternative the
nordic duo of eriksen and nokia
are waiting in the wings with their own
5g technology
right here in europe but angela merkel's
own team has been divided
with the economy minister representing
business in favor of huawei
and the foreign minister who's worried
about geopolitics
against even the security services have
been sending contradictory signals
the head of germany's foreign
intelligence the bnd
has warned against huawei while the bsi
which is the body responsible for tech
security
has suggested it can manage the risks
meanwhile some of germany's big networks
like deutsche telekom have already
started
installing huawei's 5g equipment
they say that ripping it all out again
would cost huge amounts of money
all adding to the pressure for a clear
decision from the top
ultimately angela merkel in her office
back there
is going to have to come down on one
side or the other
huawei's critics like the liberal free
democrat
party say that she must er on the side
of caution
well we cannot be sure that our data our
information that
is transferred through 5g is
secure and is not maybe used by
ccp for other reasons and as long as we
cannot rule that out
i would rule out far away from this
buildup it all comes back down to that
crucial question that we began with
of trust you need to view
digital technologies the coming
5g the internet of things surveillance
issues
we need to view them through the prism
of democratic security
now that will mean national security in
some ways but it basically means
political security and that you need to
support the values
of democracy of of of the separation of
powers of the rule of law
within these systems and ensure that
they follow what are at the end of the
day
values that are very very important here
in germany and in europe
and i think that given the realities the
political and the economic realities in
china i don't see
how chinese companies can match those
expectations
if you start to follow that thought a
little further down the road
you start to imagine a world divided
between those who pursue democratic
values and those who don't
between those we trust and those we
don't
something like a new cold war and nobody
says that that's what they want
but we may end up looking back on this
decision about huawei
as a turning point